g'day mates its Alicia Malone for
Fandango movie clips with your insider's
guide into Mad Max fury road first up
the franchise Mad Max is a
post-apocalyptic series of films created
by Australian director dr. George Miller
centered around badass loner Max
Rockatansky played in three of the
movies by Mel Gibson fury road is the
fourth film in the series which started
in 1979 with Mad Max followed by the
road warrior and finally beyond the
Thunderdome next the timeline it's been
30 years since the last Mad Max and fury
road was held back for years by numerous
production delays but George Miller was
determined to get it made and though
this is the fourth film in the series
Miller says should think of it like this
if max is a mythic character then many
stories would have been told about him
fury road is one of those stories so
it's not necessarily a prequel for a
sequel or a fourth wheel for like
another episode now the story
fury road has been described as a
Western on wheels set in a toxic
wasteland the villain the immortan an
evil warlord who enslaves women to give
milk to his troops
yikes young boys who are fighting for
him because they believe they'll be
granted a better life the only hope for
the women and the boys Mad Max and a
tough heroine called furiosa the two
team up to cross the desert and fight
next the cast in the iconic role of Max
is Tom Hardy the English actor has
carved out an incredible career playing
tough guys and looks right at home in
the rough setting of fury road playing
furiosa is the one and only Charlize
Theron and with this character the Oscar
winner looks set to bring us a new
iconic female hero rounding out the cast
is nicholas hoult zoe kravitz Riley
Keough rosie huntington-whiteley
abuelita Shaw and Courtney Eaton and
finally the action what Mad Max is known
for George Miller was determined to fill
the movie with as many practical effects
and high-octane stunts as he could be
shot on real locations crashed many real
cars and use the best real stuntmen he
could find the intention being to make
everything feel realistic gritty and
dangerous and in this age of
computer-generated special
facts that's rare that was your
insider's guide to Mad Max fury road in
theaters May 15 for Fandango movie clips
I'm Alicia Malone fight